well imagine snowfields and that that's
as an analogous to this background field
you know throughout all the universe and
this reflects the way that people
crossing it in in in different ways
depending on whether they wear skis or
snowshoes or just boots and the analogy
is then that they the people with skis
relatively unaffected in trouble with
high high speed the people with no shoes
do not quite so well and the people who
just wear boots go very slowly and that
analogy is with the effect on some kinds
of particles which continue to travel
this speed of light and the massless and
that what happens to particles which are
heavier but to me that's that well that
contains lessons of physics than my more
roundabout explanation